عاد انه شطاع على مواقع التواصل اجتماعي
نشره فيديو لسمكه ان تعيش في الصحراء تسمى
السمكه القط او الكتفش واظهر الفيديو
الرجل وهو يحمل السمكه التي تعيش بيئه
صيفيا لسنوات طويله وهذا النوع من الاسماك
تمتلك رئه كاذبه تساعدها على البقاء خارج
سطح الماء بما يقارب بثمانيه اشهر
هيا يا ابو سعد
اعثر حظا من هذا الرجل تباعا لما وصفه
رواد مؤقت التواصل الاجتماعي بعد انتشار
مقطع فيديو يظهر ما حدث مع موظفا في
البرازيل تم تعيينه حديثا في محل اطارات
تسبب في ضرب المدير بعصا حديديه مرتين
وخرج باصابه مؤلمه للمتابع
[موسيقى]
اتاري مقطع فيديو تداولته مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اعجاب السعوديين ظهر فيه رجل
المرور وهو يقوم باجباري احد المخالفين
للانظمه في احد الشوارع الرياض على التوقف
بالقوه مشيطين باداء رجل الشرطه في هذا
الموقف الخطير لنشاهد
[موسيقى]
ههه
في الصين من خصوماتي شركه السيارات تسلا
تداولت وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مقاطع
فيديو الاحتجاجات قام بها السكان الذين
اشتروا سيارات تسلا قبل فتره وجيزه حيث
اعلنت الشركه عن خصومات تصل الى 24%
مقارنه بشهر سبتمبر من العام الماضي
ويطالبون باعاده فرق السعر اليهم
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم